months where do you think work out oh
okay 12 months from now 2024 we have the
harbing we could be at the same price
we're at now I wouldn't be surprised if
we're at late 20s moving towards 30s
um but I I could get an approximation
for 2025. I'm definitely like okay not
Financial advice but I would say 250
000 2025. no Financial advice not
Financial advice PCA be safe don't do
any crazy stuff yeah I got into Bitcoin
I was originally working as a journalist
and I actually kind of fell into it but
as soon as I was exposed to it I
understood that it was decentralized 21
million and so I thought wow this has to
be the future of money and so that's
what I love about it money that
governments can't touch totally
non-corrupt